[Music]
foreign
there are several biological and
scientific reasons why a creature the
size of Godzilla could never exist in
real life well we do know that
Godzilla's unique Titan biology allows
him to overcome such limiting factors
since he is a radioactive Immortal Kaiju
but here we will only discuss real
science and why creature not necessarily
Godzilla himself but let's say another
like him would be impossible in real
life
the first one of course is the square
Cube law as an animal grows larger its
volume and weight increase at a faster
rate than its surface area in comparison
this means that an animal the size of
Godzilla would need proportionally
thicker and stronger bones muscles and
other tissues to support its weight and
move its massive body it's highly
unlikely that any biological material
could ever evolve to be strong enough to
support such a creature of that size
unless the bones are made of titanium or
carbon fiber and even with such
materials constant movement will induce
cracks and fractures that will
eventually cause the creature to crumble
on its own weight
the second limiting factor is energy
requirement a creature the size of
Godzilla would require an enormous
amount of food and energy to sustain
itself even if such a creature had
access to almost unlimited food supply
it is highly unlikely that it could
consume enough to support its massive
body and Metabolism for example an adult
elephant can consume about 300 pounds of
food per day to meet its energy needs
similarly some dinosaurs were estimated
to consume up to 500 pounds of food per
day now for an animal the size of
Godzilla there would be no amount of
food souls in any specific Niche or
ecosystem coupled with the energy output
to find such food Souls the cause versus
benefit analysis would deem this highly
unsustainable in the long run
number three respiration as animals get
larger it becomes more difficult for
oxygen to diffuse through their tissues
which can limit their ability to extract
oxygen from the air or water a creature
the size of Godzilla will require an
incredibly efficient respiratory system
to sustain its massive body which is
highly unlikely to evolve naturally
respiration can certainly be a limiting
factor as an animal would require a
large amount of oxygen to fuel its
metabolism large animals like whales
have adaptations to increase their
respiratory efficiency such as larger
lungs or specialized air sacs however it
is unclear whether a creature the size
of Godzilla which is multiple times or
hundreds of times bigger than a whale
would have similar adaptations or a
unique respiratory system in any case
respiration which is essentially not
just breathing in and out but the entire
purpose of breaking down of food into
energy for metabolism would in turn
generate another limiting factor
now we come to the fourth limiting
factor which is heat dissipation large
animals generate more heat than small
animals and it becomes increasingly
difficult to dissipate that heat that's
the animal's size increases as animals
become larger their surface area to
volume ratio decreases which means that
they have a smaller surface area
relative to their volume this can make
it more difficult for them to dissipate
their excess heat which can lead to
overheating and other physiological
problems for their cells tissues and
organs a creature the size of the G-Man
would need a highly efficient cooling
system to avoid overheating having
dorsal plates might help but we're
talking real science here fictionally
Godzilla is already an overheated
radioactive monster Titan let's say
there are some physiological traits that
would minimize this heat dissipation but
what would the excess heat inside the
body do to the next limiting factor
and this is the nervous system it's
highly likely that the nervous system of
a creature the size of Godzilla would
work most slowly than that of small
animals this is because Nerf impulses
travel through neurons at a finite speed
which is determined by the properties of
the nerve fibers and the concentrations
of the ions in the extracellular fluid
as an animal gets larger the distance
between its brain and its extremities
increases and the length of its nerves
grow accordingly this means that it
takes longer for nerve impulses to
travel from the brain to the body and
back again which can result in slower
reflexes and reaction times and even
movement there are also limits to the
size of nerve fibers Beyond which it
becomes more difficult or even
impossible for impulses to travel
efficiently and the excess heat would
just mess it all up burn the fibers and
just mess up the iron Exchange
number six The evolutionary limitations
so it's worth noting that there are
evolutionary constraints that limit the
size of animals for example there are
physical limits to how large an animal's
heart can be and still pump blood
effectively throughout the body as well
as limits to how fast an animal can move
its limbs relative to its size these and
other constraints make it highly
unlikely that a creature the size of
Godzilla would ever evolve naturally The
evolutionary factor is the most
interesting part here since animals
usually evolve after a long succession
of inheritable viable point mutations
passed down through their children's or
offsprings and these point mutations are
located in the genes that allow certain
phenotypes or phenotypic traits to
enhance and thereby allow The Offspring
or the creature specimen to succeed in
procreation and passing Down The Helpful
characteristics to their offsprings for
survival and dominance there have been
many large animals that have been
extinct due to their size like the
Spinosaurus and the brachiosaurus and
why it is actually a constraint for them
for their size to find food and mates so
evolving larger in the grand scheme of
things isn't really an evolutionary
success story
and lastly number seven reproduction as
animals get larger it becomes more
difficult for them to find suitable
mates and reproduce a creature the size
of Godzilla would need a large
population to avoid genetic inbreeding
which would be difficult to sustain in a
limited habitat like the Earth even if
inbreeding wasn't an issue and there is
a chance that a hybrid Vigor or inbred
offsprings that are actually tougher
were possible their size and ability to
find enough food to grow into adulthood
and become sexually mature themselves
would be a very tiny success rate which
would mean that they would have to
forage for food all around the world and
what if they die due to starvation and
or sickness before another specimen of
the other sex the opposite sex meets
them for procreation so yeah that's a
bummer
so taking together all these factors
make it highly unlikely or even possible
that a creature the size of Godzilla
could ever exist in reality while it is
suddenly possible to imagine such a
creature in the context of science
fiction or fantasy it's important to
remember that the real world biology and
physics play significant constraints on
what is possible for life forms so I
hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam